Obamacare the train wreck continues I've
been for this thing I believe that
everyone can and should have health care
but the website not working well and
even the libs are turning on it and they
say when you've lost John Stuart you've
lost the country and it looks like Obama
may have lost John Stuart maybe a bit
concerning that the president was not
kept in the loop about the program that
is named after him but in his defense
there appeared to be very few loops for
the first time the government reveals
that it monitored some 35 world leaders
including German Chancellor Angela
Merkel perhaps more shocking is that
President Obama was kept in the dark
about it for five years so for five
years
I assume the president is being
presented with the findings from this
world leader monitoring and in those
five years that never occurred to him to
say how we getting this does the
president believe in surveillance
fairies all right so he didn't know
about this NSA thing you know whether
you think Benghazi the Scambler or not
he didn't really know about that or the
IRS but what's really getting him is all
the quotes that they have of him talking
about Obamacare remember if you like
your plan you can keep it period you can
keep your plan if you are satisfied with
it if you like the plan you have you can
keep it if you like your plan and you
like your doctor you won't have to do a
thing you keep your plan if you like
your health care plan you'll be able to
keep your health care plan if you've got
health insurance you can keep it if you
like your health care plan you will keep
your plan if you've got health insurance
do you like your doctor you like your
plan you can keep your doctor you can
keep your plan if you have insurance
that you like then you will be able to
keep that insurance if you like your
doctor or health care plan you can keep
it if you like your health care plan you
can keep your health care plan
alright so New York Magazine put that
compilation together and it actually
goes further than that but this is
YouTube so we got time constraints okay
so let's start with this first off just
from watching that little clip right
there before we get to the Jon Stewart
stuff do you think politicians all hate
YouTube and hey
the internet because we can now track
the lies you know even ten years ago you
couldn't track the lies yeah I think
somebody reporters were still tracking
the lies but but everyone can get it at
a quick now any troll can do it but but
I definitely think that this is
something that would have been caught
regardless and I guess the big question
is is this actually a lie or is this
something where he was trying to sell
the the country an idea that in his mind
was fully formed that he then had to
pass in the Congress in order to you
know implement it and so he was selling
an idea that was one idea and then as we
all knew the law was changed piecemeal
by piecemeal in order to get it to pass
right so do you think he possibly didn't
know that he was gonna end up lying
because everyone's saying they changed
so much the whole story is Miss Lee
because the there's a cherry-picking of
anecdotal evidence that shows some
people have had to give up plans right
that's a tiny percentage 5% of the
people who are previously insured we're
now having to give up their insurance
and those five are having to give up
their insurance because their insurance
was inadequate
it just doesn't meet the requirements of
the mandate and many of those will be up
for help
governmental help for for paying for the
new insurance right supposedly they'll
get center insurance you know that's not
what it said it seems doing that they
will get better insurance yes but their
premiums are gonna go up there's a
subsidy that can come in to help cover
that that premium going up so what we're
really dealing with is not a question
whether he lied but whether he
underestimated how low people would go
in their insurance before they were
dissatisfied with it he was thinking
well clearly people who have really
crappy insurance don't like their
insurance right if you have insurance
you like you're gonna be able to keep
anyone know I really liked my crappy
insurance right which he just didn't
anticipate but what is he thinking that
or was he doing what you're saying which
I tend to think is probably a little
closer to truth which is he just had to
sell it so he had to keep repeating that
because he had to sell it and then once
it's through then all the nuance of the
little details that you're describing
come to light but he had to sell it so
he had to keep saying I mean it's one
thing to call somebody out on a lie
about something that hasn't happened yet
you know that's a failed promise more
than it is I think a bold-faced lie it's
one thing to lie and you know who knows
what's going on with the NSA tapes right
with all of this evidence we don't know
what Obama was privy to and what he
wasn't and we don't know how much of
that truth he's actually hiding but I
think preemptively to say in the future
things will be this way is that really
lying right it's really just an over
promise and I don't I don't I still
think it's not even an over promise he
just didn't realize that there would be
people who went no I like crappy
insurance yeah and that you know that
wouldn't occur to me exactly okay so
let's get to what we started with which
is the John Stuart stuff because I do
think it's interesting that John who
really basically is the most trusted man
in media is sort of turning against
Obama and it has more to do with the NSA
stuff I think and I've been talking
about this for weeks on here it seems to
me that they purposely don't tell Obama
things that they don't tell him at the
website for Obama care wasn't quite
gonna work it's now come out he didn't
know and he didn't know that the NSA was
spying like tactic I think in large
corporations where the CEO ultimately
you know holds the responsibility for
decisions that are made so you know the
board may make a decision or people
underneath it may make a decision and
intentionally but not disclosed at him
so that he can't then later be held
responsible is that a decent way for
government ivory was pioneered by the
darling of the right Ronald Reagan it is
under his administration that we were
introduced to the expression plausible
deniability right and it's have that
written right here it's a deliberate
thing and I think it's very dangerous
it's you know the buck stops here so
please don't show me the buck if it
comes near me I have to stop it so
please keep the buck in the waiting room
I would like an antechamber full of
bucks is that deniability really
plausible yes you
exactly you see the results from the
wiretap how do you not know that they
came from a wiretap right and and also
you know it's funny you bring up the
puzzle of deniability cuz I do have it
written here but I have it written not
because of Reagan and I'm glad you
brought that up I've ER in because of
the movie Independence Day because
remember when Bill Pullman the president
finds out about the aliens and he says
well why didn't I know about this and
they go plausible deniability so I get
more that's where I get my information
from your problem I understand I well
you know Ronald Reagan really took
plausible deniability to a whole new low
kuzuri his second term as president he
didn't know he was president the level
of plausible deniability there is really
extraordinary yeah okay so if this if
the system is built so that they
purposely don't tell him things and then
that way he's not quite like then who's
really in charge here
like is this Illuminati stuff what are
we really talking about NSA really in
charge and and or is the FBI like well I
mean ultimately in the grand scheme of
things we know the big money this is a
really charge but but fundamentally I
mean there there's a reason that we have
a division of power in this country
right there's a reason that we have the
three different branches of government
so that they can impose checks and
balances on one another the hope is that
the executor isn't ultimately in charge
because that would be too much power for
one leader in a democracy but at the
same time when it comes to the NSA
scenario I think that things are getting
really really out of hand we even saw
that Dianne Feinstein now is saying that
like she disapproves of wiretapping of
all of our allies in diplomatic arenas
well she's right many I mean she was one
of the people who ordered these things
yeah okay so let's wrap up with this
thing because I think it's a great point
this idea that every time something gets
leaked by Snowden everyone pretends
they're outraged except we all feel like
we knew that this stuff was going on so
how does nine Feinstein sit there in
front of the committee and pretend she
either pretends she doesn't know we're
now we're not going to do it anymore
you've been doing that we have never
done such a thing we will never do such
a thing and we've stopped we won't ever
again but fundamentally I think the
issue is that this is a it's a political
move it's not a move about keeping
Americans safe as well
we knew that our own phones could be
wiretap nobody seemed to have a problem
with it on the NSA and Teller on the
Intelligence Committee
in Congress but as soon as there were
there diplomacy was at stake right as
soon as this was detrimental to any sort
of political agenda all of a sudden this
is something that we shouldn't be doing
but all right we do aren't we doing it
our allies and our allies doing it to us
like this is this just standard spy
verse pie like psych 101 I think I think
that's true but I also think that we
have capabilities that are far beyond a
fair amount of other nations and so in
some times in some ways we have the
upper hand there I think we like to keep
sense that we are far more
technologically advanced than we are
just for the sake of keeping the
populace intimidated a little bit and I
think there is a lot of of stuff going
on between the NSA the CIA the FBI and
of course b613 that where secrets are
being kept from each other for the sake
of proprietary information gathering and
and data sourcing that is so dangerous
and so ugly and so nefarious that to
some degree at least even the
Intelligence Committee is shocked every
time they realize that they're not they
are not being told everything because we
have three branches of government and
then a whole bunch of super secret
organizations and I think it's ugly and
I and I think we should all stop
pretending that what we live in is a
land of freedom and and free expression
you just gave me the perfect out for a
segment so there you hey guys the Rubin
reports brought to you by Cooper comm
they have up to 75% off pet treats
choose toys and more and if you use code
RR you get another 20% that's a lot of
percentage right there I can't do that
kind of math the link is right down
below
Cooper comm code RR